alors justement le parc des princes et
une grande semaine pour les amateurs de
football parisien puisque le parc des
princes va être utilisé pour la première
fois cette semaine
oui car si l'inauguration officielle
aura lieu le 4 juin en présence du
président de la république contre bastia
pour la grande finale de la coupe de
france
il y aura six jeux se dire une sorte de
test un match pré inaugurale cette
semaine jeudi en effet les footballeurs
amateurs français vont recevoir leurs
homologues russes atteste également pour
la télévision nous vous convions
d'ailleurs maintenant visiter ce tout
nouveau parc des princes
c'est parce que sa surface était
réservée naguère aux jeux des enfants
royaux qu'il fut baptisé par des princes
depuis sa construction en 1896 jusqu'à
sa démolition en 1967
le parc s'est transformé en haut lieu du
sport français équipe de france de
football le racing club de paris et même
le stade de reims à l'occasion de la
coupe d'europe en firent leur terrain
favori
quant à sa fille ste rose elle fut le
théâtre de sprint mémorable chacun étant
désireux d'inscrire son nom au palmarès
de la dernière étape du tour de france
et surtout de revêtir définitivement le
maillot jaune mais 1972 télé midi vous
ouvre les portes du tout nouveau parc
des princes
on doit ces lignes pures à l'architecte
qui a fait construire font romeu et qui
signera bientôt le stade olympique de
montréal
existe-t-il d'ailleurs plusieurs
solutions pour le maître d'oeuvre
lorsqu'il s'agit de construire une arène
de 50000 places au milieu d'un tissu
urbain ma réponse est que sauf table a
été construit à la fuite
de nombreuses études parallèles avant de
fixer un choix nous sommes dans un tissu
très dense avec des limites
périphériques qui existait tout autour
de cette réflexion et empêcher une
structure va dire faciale dépassant les
limites du terrain je ne pourrais
prendre comme exemple le stade de munich
est construit sur un grand espace avec
des structures tendu qui demandent des
plantes fondation beaucoup plus éloignés
ici alors que là nous avons au contraire
resserré la base du stade pour permettre
des circulations comme dans une arène ce
stade en fait vous lever coucher sur le
papier il ya déjà cinq ans en 1967
aujourd'hui si le parc des princes
d'état refaire qu'est ce que vous y
changeriez on leur fait jouer deux fois
la même chose donc
après l'expérience nous avons eu deux
structures il est possible d'apporter
dès lors de modifications
bien que ce stade soit le premier en
europe qui était être été entièrement
couverts sans point d'appui avec une
visibilité totale sur l'ensemble de ce
serait pareil
mais on pourrait parfaire cette
installation par des rampes d'accès par
des escaliers mécaniques et supprimer
ainsi tous les escaliers
c'est à mon avis la rançon des études de
demain et les réalisations de van bommel
300 m de métal dominici 600 mille mètres
cubes de béton 57 km de câbles
chauffants sont répartis sous la pelouse
qui sera donc réfractaires aux jeunes
cette véritable moquette gazonné est née
en hollande
voici deux ans déjà pour l'éclairer de
ses douze sans luxe des projecteurs
orientable qui permettront naturellement
les retransmissions télévisées en
couleurs
je dis simplement qu'il aurait fallu
faire des essais et une liaison pour
savoir quelles banques de quelques mois
je suis incapable de dire à l'oeil
à l'heure actuelle c'est sale bonhomme
social bon exemple
j'allais faire des essais placer les
caméras il fallait faire des recherches
déplacements de caméra
rené-luc au ce nouvel outil vous
convient-il pas parfaitement
je pense d'abord aux télés reporter il
faut pas oublier que lorsque les les
stades ont été construits en france
la télévision et la radio n'existait pas
la presse filmée elle existait déjà
alors on a installé la presse filmée
dans de bonnes conditions quand la radio
et la télévision sont apparus on les
amis ou dans les espaces libres dans les
chambres de bonnes sources ou pente
maintenant on a transformé les chambres
de bonne en studio mais ça reste quand
même les chambres de bonne et je pensais
que dans un nouveau stade que les radios
reporter l'état les reporter seraient
traitées sur un pied d'égalité avec les
journalistes de la pression mais il n'y
a aucune raison qu'un reporter de
télévision qui parle pour des millions
de téléspectateurs ne soit pas à une
place privilégiée alors que certains
journalistes travaillent pour quelqu'un
journal confidentielles et en ce qui
concerne vos caméras proprement dit
la plateforme centrale me paraît bien
installés les cameramen seront à l'aise
je regrette qu'il n'y a pas de
possibilité de prise de vue derrière
chaque but à la hauteur début il n'y a
rien au but de prévu à la hauteur du 18
mai télé corner on a réinstallé la
plateforme de télévision
exactement comme j'ai fait construire en
1938 pour la finale de la coupe du monde
la plateforme qui sert depuis 35 ans à
colombes
aux 50000 places assises correspondent
autant de sièges en plastique pour y
accéder il faudra être bien en souffre
ce qui est somme toute naturelle pour un
public qui se veut sportif il sera
également nécessaire de conserver votre
ligne sans quoi vous risqueriez
d'attirer quelque peu les foot de votre
voisin lorsque le parc sera plein comme
un oeuf
quelques centaines de spectateurs se
verront contraints de suivre les débats
au travers des grilles de protection
séparant les tribunes pour la finale de
la coupe ou débourserait entre 10 et 70
francs n'est ce pas trop coûteux pour un
spectacle qui se veut populaire
il s'agit de la finale de la coupe de
france de l'inauguration du nouveau parc
des princes et de la présence de
monsieur le président de la république
j'ai le sentiment très net que les
fédérations concessionnaires ont profité
de cette occasion pour majorer les
places mais je souhaite et j'espère bien
que pour les matchs à venir au parc
dépasse les prix sont nettement
inférieurs le prix de revient de ce parc
des princes a fait poulet vous savez
beaucoup d'ordres certains ont parlé de
scandale financier
d'autres au contraire disent que c'est
le stade de moins chère d'europe à
l'heure où se situe la vérité bien il
faut comparer ce qui vient de se
réaliser au parc des princes avec ce qui
a été réalisé ces dix dernières années
en matière de stades de par le monde à
mexico
le prix de la place est revenue à plus
de 3000 francs nouveau et à munich
actuellement je crois savoir que les
5000 francs nouveaux sont dépassés il
est exact qu'à paris le prix de la place
revient actuellement à 10 800 francs
puisque la construction outre 90
millions pour 50000 places
le prix du terrain n'étant pas inclus
dans les dix huit ans mais nous pouvons
regretter c'est que la construction du
parc des princes a été très mal
présentée devant conseil de paris car je
vous rappelle que les premières études
on peut estimer le prix de revient à 45
millions de nouveaux francs et
actuellement nous sommes à 90 quelques
conseils pratiques
évitez de vous rendre au parc des
princes avec votre voiture vous
risqueriez d'assister au match bien
après le coup d'envoi
il nie en effet que 3500 places de
parking mais le secteur est fort bien
desservi en transports urbains attention
aussi si vous résidez du côté de la
porte de saint-cloud quatre heures avant
les matchs un périmètre bien précis sera
interdite à la circulation si donc vous
êtes riverain et que vous ne possédez
pas encore votre laissez-passer fait
comme ce monsieur qui va le retirer au
commissariat du xvième arrondissement
et maintenant place au sport dans ce
remarquable monument érigé en sa gloire